sketching for
Max perfect yeah good you can hear me
yes all right good so I wanted to talk
about some streaming low bonds but then
I decided not to because I've been
talking about
those couple of times recently and then
I feel like the audience will get too
tired of that so I'm going to instead
talk about an adoptive sketching upper
bound um the let me write the title
so
TI can you see it or can you it
sure this was just for the title all
right this is
better all right okay perfect so so I
will go through what is this problem and
I'll Define it one thing to say this is
an extremely simple algorithm so there's
no G like I'm not trying to hide
anything I'm trying to show you an
algorithm which is like super simple and
I hope to just go through all of it this
in this stuff all right good so what are
talking about we are talking about
maximum weight matching problem the
problem is just this thing you have a
graph very
[Music]
example one two six seven eight so you
have a graph it's not necessarily even
bipartite you have some weights over the
edges and what you want to do is that
you want to pick bunch of edges that do
not share a vertex and you want to
maximize the weight okay so the standard
maximum weight matching problem and here
I guess the answer for instance will be
nine you can get a maximum matching of
weight nine and I don't think you can do
better the nine is like you can pick
this one and this Edge sounds
good and let's say we can't do
better so we are so this is fundamental
problem like there's Nots of results
known in this problem in different
models one nice thing about matching is
that it's a very good problem to try out
different algorithmic techniques for it
like lots of I mean you've heard of
complexity class P know and that started
when Edmonds start looking at
non-bipartite matching and like
designing classical algorithm for it and
so my goal is also doing that we want to
just develop some algorithmic technique
in the context of match
um so we are looking at graph sketching
uh we talked about this model I
guess so graph sketching is this you're
going to think of your graph as a very
long Vector
of its edges basically you look at this
n choose two pair of possible so your
graph has n vertices you look at this
and choose two pair of vertices and this
Vector has let's say for now it is uned
okay so you'll write one here 0 one 0 0
1 this means that the first two vertices
for instance have an edge between them
this is instead of adjacency Matrix I
just write it in a vector okay so this
is my graph a sketching algorithm does
the following you pick a matrix a
usually think of this so this is a very
tall Vector think of multiplying it by a
fat Matrix of
a of s time
n and when you do the multiplication you
get a smaller
Vector Dimension s okay and these are
these are because this is integer it
matters the bit representation of a
should be a small also otherwise I can
just multiply with one random Matrix of
very large values and I just store
everything in a single number okay so
one thing is that my a also has a small
numbers inside like the the
representation of this s is just order s
poogan
bits sounds good okay so
what does a depend on N uh a n or G so
so the question is that does a depends
on N um on the number of vertices for
sure but should it depend on this graph
or not okay and the answer is no but let
me get to that okay so if you do
something like this for sure this is not
a lossless compression like you are
going to lose something this is n two
you're compressing it down to something
so you are going to lose some
information but we are we would like to
do this thing and preserve some certain
property of the graph okay I don't want
to store the entire graph here I want to
do this thing and then when I look at
the sketch I can find a large matching
from it or I can find a spanning tree
from does that make
sense now when I want to do that the
question is how do I choose
a there is always an easy way I can look
at my graph I find its maximum matching
and I just pick a in the way that pick
those edges and put them here okay
that's not interesting when what you do
in a sketching is that the matx a is
chosen without looking at the graph you
pick some distribution like any other
sketching there's some
distribution you sample a from that
distribution and then you multiply it
with this Matrix and then you get your
sketch does that sound good that's gra
it's the same as sketching like I'm not
saying anything new and it's a very
useful model you can use it to design
graph streaming algorithms you can use
it to create parallel algorithms fast
algorithm
Etc so we want to look at graph
sketching in the context of the matching
problem any question about the
setting so let me try to list I mean now
that I'm using a board it's hard to list
lots of references but let me just say
something here so graph sketching was
introduced in this very nice work of and
Gohan and M
gregar that they designed this model and
they show that actually you can solve
lots of nontrivial problem with it you
can solve things like graph
connectivity you can find Edge
connectivity and things like that okay
and there are lots of work here we now
know now let me just list some results
we now how to find cus
falsifiers or even a spectral
sparsifiers or we can do let's say Delta
[Applause]
coloring this
is and lots of other things so so there
are lots of problems we can create a
sketch for them oh
okay we can create a sketch of size
proportional to the answer itself O Okay
so one thing I forgot to mention here
that we want a sketches of
size so I'm having a very large vector
and I want to compress it down to
something which is proportional to
number of vertices and for most of these
problems it's very easy to argue that
you cannot go below
that if you're outputting like if you're
outputting n edges in a matching you
cannot compress to something less
time so there lots of sketches of this
form and I can slightly distinguish
between this there Bunch so these these
ones use really the real power of
sketching okay there are bunch of other
algorithms here also for instance for
dens sub graph or for Delta plus one
coloring they're more or less you just
do sampling so you don't need a heavy
machinery of sketching let's say you can
just sample the edges and just use your
sketches to do sampling and then you can
solve those problems as well
[Applause]
so
so so this is a long list here there are
lots of problems we can solve but if you
notice I didn't talk about matching okay
so for matching for a while we didn't
know how to do graph sketching in fact
and there is a good reason uh you can
prove that there are no efficient
sketches for matching so if my task is
to get this graph multiplied by some
Matrix and get something that has o and
be able to recover a large matching from
it we know now that there are lower
bonds that roll that out so for
matching proves a very strong lower Bond
it says that if you want to be able to
preserve a large matching with a sketch
of size o line
the best approximation Factor you get is
only n to the 1/3 okay so you are not
going to be able to get a good a sketch
for the maximum matching problem does
this make
sense and there are some works here that
you we know exactly what is the
complexity of this problem down to the
constant really or like ASM totically
okay um but I will not talk about that
okay this is this sketchings tell like
these results tell tells me that we
cannot solve the matching using the
sketching problem like this set sounds
good so then what would you do if this
doesn't work the next step which was
already looked at in this very first
paper that what if I do adoptive way of
sketching so I cannot sketch it in one
go but maybe I can do this thing
adaptively a couple of times what does
that mean is the
[Applause]
following
[Music]
remember in the past my sketching goal
was that I designed a distribution that
has nothing to do with this graph I
sample a from it multiply with my input
I get the sketch okay now if I want to
do this adaptively I'm going to do this
operations in
rounds in round one I do exactly the
same thing I sample a from some
distribution D and I'll get a * X let me
call it
A1 sounds good so I I learned something
about my graph and now I'm going to
design a distribution let's if this was
D1 I'm going to design a distribution D2
that this time D2 depends on my graph to
this
sketch I learned something about the
graph so let me use that information so
now D2 is function of D2 of
a1x make
sense maybe you look at the graph and
you decided that these set of vertices
are more important I want to sample more
edges from there so my next distribution
tries to sample more edges from I'll
pick something from here so now I'll
sample A2 from
here I'll do the multiplication I get A2
off so this is my second round in my
third round I I put these two together
this is the information I know about my
graph I design my distribution D3 and
use that to sample A3 and I do this
thing maybe for all
rounds so is the model clear at the end
I just use this information to Output
let's say the
match why is this useful well the same
way that you can use the sketches in a
streaming setting you can now use this
to design a multipass streaming
algorithm if you need all rounds of
adaptive sketching you get an R pass
streaming algorithm in the first pass
compute the first sketch use it to do
the sampling in the next pass use the
next round and so on and so forth or
you'll get a multi round parallel
algorithm a map reduce algorithm so the
same thing and here again this AGM paper
for instance show that
if you do order login rounds of this
type of a sketching you can find
something like minimum spanning tree
which we know you cannot do in a single
round so now let's do something simple
let me see if there
[Applause]
is I want to start with a switch to the
more algorithmic
part
[Applause]
is
so I want to show you a very simple
algorithm that if you do order the login
rounds of sketching allows you to
recover maximal matching which is a two
approximation so we couldn't get
anything near that in one round but in
order Logan rounds I can get something
and by the way the goal is to limit the
number of runs as small as possible
login is already large but beyond we
don't really want to go even beyond the
constant would have been ideal but at
least
log does anyone see actually how to do
something like
this one thing I should tell you
sketching allow you to sample something
from the graph you can spend poly Logan
rows here and Sample an edge uniform at
random from the graph so sampling is
like one of the simplest form of a
sketching
so in fact all the sketching things that
I'm going to tell you today fit into
this set they're they're really just
sampling algorithm I'm not going to use
the power of sketching in any way I just
want to sample from and there's a simple
way of getting a maximal matching just
sample order and edges from your graph
okay uniformly at random so now you have
order and edges compute a maximal
matching over those edges okay and then
remove all the vertices that are
matched now you have another smaller
graph sample order and edges from that
Gra
remove the vertices that are matched and
just continue doing this thing and it's
a greedy algorithm you can just append
whatever thing that you sample you can
just add it to the like whatever
matching you compute in each round you
can just add it to the end end of the
matching you have so the algorithm is
this this is Maxim all matching
and this is the entire algorithm sample
order and adjust compute a maximum
matching M of your
sample remove everything that you've
matched and recurse and if you pick if
you get M1 M2 that you are picking is
disjoint from it you remove the match
vertices so you can just add it to the
end of it and you get M3 And just pack
add it at the
end and why does this algorithm
work
question sorry I was just trying to
understand why you able to do this onlys
like good yeah so so let's get why this
thing terminates I will not prove this
but there are two ways of proving
something something like this this ideas
goes back to Lu's Mis algorithm you can
prove one of these two both of these are
true
one number of
edges round
R you can prove that in each round at
least half of the edges of the graph are
being
removed it cannot be that if you're
sampling order n edges if you start with
a graph that has n Square edges after
you do this operation and you remove the
Matched vertices you cannot have too
many edges left and the intuition is
that if you have too many edges left
that you've you know none of those edges
should have been sampled and if you have
so many edges why didn't you sample
them so one way is this and a slightly
more a Sleek argument you can actually
say that the max
degree is is also less than n / 2 to the
r we can even prove something like this
the maximum degree of this graph keeps
going down and if you prove either of
this thing you can prove that in order
Logan rounds you're going to end up your
graph becomes empty you have a match
sounds good these are these are really
easy exercises you can prove them on
your own in like five
minutes yeah I something about this
recursion I I mean you allow yourself
the n space where n is the number of
vertices in the original graph yes but n
keeps kind of decreasing or something is
decreasing as you go along so one might
expect you would do even better because
in later rounds you would accelerate or
something that's that's an amazing Point
yes and we here we don't know how to do
it for some other problem like maximal
Independence that we can do it and we
get order log log and rounds here for
some reasons it doesn't seem that that
work that's a very good point
yes
any other
question so this is a general this fil
tring or like subsequent work called s
plan PR this is a very generic way of
taking any greedy algorithm and
implement it using these sketching
techniques okay you can Implement many
many gy algorithm for sub modular
maximization for like finding base of
like minimum weight base of a matroid
things like that you can really
implement it in this
but one minus Epsilon approximate
matching is not a strictly speaking a
greedy solution okay greedy just gives
you two so we want to use something like
this and go all the way to something
that give us one minus Epsilon
approxim
instances speaking of the previous
question by jalani I feel like there be
instances where the speling removes just
a one over log and fraction of vertices
per round so then basically for the
first like Logan rounds the number of
vertices doesn't really go down so yeah
so Michel's question is that this
algorithm I think what Jal suggest thing
you can interpret it that this algorithm
itself should become better okay this
algorithm is tight it's tight even in a
stronger settings that there are models
of computation that you can Define that
and you can prove unconditional
communication complexity lower Bonds in
those models for algorithms in this
family okay so it's not entirely clear
you can be and you're completely right
peeling is not going to get better than
log
and but for the sketching problem itself
it is not known that whether you need
log and rounds
on all right
so
so let me say one other thing here
before going to the algorithm so this
gives us two approxim two approximation
there are also some generic ways of
boosting approximation of matching to
something better okay so some let's say
boosting
framework they give you bounce like
this
you can pick any algorithm that you have
for to approximate matching and repeat
it adaptively a certain number of time
to make its approximation better reduce
it all the way down to one minus EPS
okay one good way of doing this thing
for instance is to like for instance
Andrew had this paper
in one/ epsilon to the power order one/
Epsilon
repetition so if you have an algorithm
that can find maximum matching if you
adoptively run it you you run it you
figure out this is particular important
part of the subgraph you recurse on that
part you continue doing that for on you
can repeat it these many times and
reduce the approximation to one minus
EPS so you can now get something which
is order log times these many rounds of
adaptivity and get one minus Epsilon
approxim let's focus on bipartite graphs
for a bit bipartite and
size on and Goa 11 I think show that
multiplicative weight you can repeat it
order one/ Epsilon
Cube very easily to reduce this thing
down to one minus Epsilon approximation
and with some more work they show it in
fact you can do one/ Epsilon Square also
this okay let
me so you can run something you can use
something like multiplicative V update
run maximum matching and
get log divided by Epsilon a square
rounds of adaptivity and solve match and
you can get this type of one using other
things also for instance there's this
auction
algorithm that gives you
that that gives you the same type of
thing sounds good okay but this Epsilon
Square seems a bit inherent to these
approaches okay to multiplicative weight
in generic form there is always this
thing auction algorithms they do not let
you go below this thing and the question
want to ask is that can I get even
better dependence on Epsilon or not can
I for instance get Logan over Epsilon
here and that's the result here um okay
so let's go first
there is order Logan over
Epsilon so go 18 show that you can
actually not necessarily repeat the
maximal matching but a slightly
different algorithm and in these many
rounds of adaptivity get one minus
Epsilon approximation to match okay so
you can go below this type of
it's not a simple algorithm really it's
this is a it's a very complicated
algorithm because it tries to do the
following it picks one of these
approximation Frameworks and want to say
that look it uses login over Epsilon
Square iteration but I want to do one
over Epsilon iteration of it in just one
rounds of adoptive sketching so you have
to collect enough information from your
graph to simulate many rounds of these
Frameworks okay and it turns it into
something very
complicated then we had a result a bit
more recently
with Aon
ug Aaron and
Kevin that gets disbound for bipartite
and
size and the nice thing about that
result was it uses something entirely
different than this Frameworks but the
nice thing is that you really converge
in that many rounds you do not try to
compress many rounds into smaller number
of rounds of adaptivity that makes it
very messy but still this is not a
simple algorithm and what I want to talk
to you today is a very simple algorithm
then get that bound log over Epsilon
runs of adaptivity one minus Epsilon
approximation works even for weighted
non-bipartite
matching and the algorithm
yeah I show
the oh bipartite and not weight just the
cardinality oh
okay all right so what is the algorithm
now sorry same question so the ag8
work so the ag18 work only showed it for
bipartite graphs no this also works in
the general setting okay so the result
that you're going to present is like the
same but different like simpler uh yeah
in terms of the result it is just
simpler it doesn't give you a new bounce
okay okay thanks in a sketching in a
streaming it does something but in a
sketching it doesn't give you anything
thank you so so let me just tell you the
algorithm if there is question so the
idea of the algorithm I want to do the
same thing okay but so I'm going to
sample order and edges but then in this
step instead of computing a maximum
matching you do something else let's say
you compute a maximum matching okay you
you have the power the sketch is in
front of you so your comput is maximum
matching and then in the instead of just
removing things I'm not going to remove
anything I'm going to rate my edges I'm
going to say that some edges are more
important okay and the way to do that is
that you look at the edges that if you
sample them they would have given you a
larger
matching and then you just increase
their
weight so you sample bunch of edges you
compute on maximum matching and then you
look at these edges that if I sample
them you get a better matching okay so
then you're just going to reinsert those
edges back into your graph okay so that
you sample them
more the question is how do you
interpret what are the edges that if you
sample them you get a larger matching
okay that's what we are going to do
so so you sample and to be a specific
you sample order n over Epsilon edges
from the graph okay um let's think of G
as being a multi graph okay so your
original graph is a multi gra so you
sample these many edges from it your
computer maximum
matching and
for just for now let's say I'm again
bipartite and
cardinality and I will tell you at the
end how to extend the algorithm in one
go to weighted and non bipartite as for
now I'm talking about bipartite
cardinality matching okay you sample
these many edges from the graph you
compute a maximum matching and a minimum
vertex
cover minimum vertex cover in bipart
graph is the same as matching they're
dual of each other so you can compute
both of them so you now have those
things then instead of doing
removing so this is the entire algorithm
okay you look at the edges so you
sampled u u is a cover of H you look at
any ede of G that is not covered by you
and you place them back into the graph
one more time if if you want to think of
them as weight you double their
weights so G had bunch of edges okay you
sampled a small number of them and you
computed a Vertex cover of that small
edges then you looked at G this is the
vertex cover you created was on a sample
so it does it's not going to cover all
the edges of the original graph some
edges are not covered take those edges
and put them one more time inside g g is
a multigraph now okay put them one more
time if you have seen Clarkson's low
dimensional LP algorithm this is doing
the same thing okay these are
constraints that are not satisfied you
just put them one more time so next time
you're sampling you're going to sample
those edges more okay there are two
copies of that edge if you do uniform
sampling you're more likely to
samp does this make sense if it is
easier
yes when you
add so when you add those edges uh you
add those edges with the corresponding
weight right so uh so for a second let's
say you are right if if I was in the
weighted case I will add them with the
same weight but for now let's say I'm in
cardinality so there are no weights I
just double their numbers I see so you
are not using the weight because because
it's a multi-graph now right so if you
okay all right yeah the reason I didn't
want to call them weights is because
there are also weight on the edges that
is the weight of the problem okay
okay um when you add like the edges back
again like is it just their probability
or like when next time you sample you
might sample like both edges you might
even sample them twice that's fine okay
but it will boost their
probabilities how much time do I have
about 10 more minutes I just you said
maximum matching not maximum yes this is
maximum and this is important that it is
Maxim all right 10 minutes is enough to
do this so so this is the algorithm yeah
let me do this
analysis it may help to think of this
thing as you're defining weights over
the edges so you have a weight QE
originally equal one and if you do not
cover it you just double that
way not
cover does it make sense you originally
instead of repeating this weight has
nothing to do with the weights of the
original graph if you want call them
importances okay originally every Edge
have the same importance edges that are
not they don't are not like being
covered you double their importance by
the way this means that you don't add
them once like whatever things you had
you just copy the whole thing again back
there so what is going on the real
important thing is that look at Qing
summation
e the
total
the total weight of the edges that you
have okay this vertex cover that you are
picking here does a lot more than just
covering the sample it almost covered
the entire graph okay in the following
sense
what does this mean means that even
though you picked youu on a small sample
if you look at back at the original
graph the total importance of edges not
covered by this vertex cover is only
Epsilon time Q only Epsilon fraction of
the edges weighted by their importances
are not being
covered this is somewhat analog of what
we were saying about the degrees there
this has a on line proof does anyone see
it
or that's true but Union Bond over
what yes you can you can really Union
Bond over all possible vertex covers and
say that if you are not able to if you
are not covering Epsilon Q fraction of
the weights you are going to sample one
of those edges through this process and
that vertex cover will not even a valid
vertex cover in
Ed if I get a chance I'll prove this
thing it really has a one line proof
okay but let me tell you why this is
this finishes the argument if you just
have that okay so CL
one of R is less than let me be a bit
more relaxed and put two
here
if you do this process this is going to
do something very similar to
multiplicative weight using Q as our
objective as your potential function the
total weights are going to increase very
slowly okay why because only Epsilon
over two Q edges are not covered those
are the ones that you double theirs
everything else you keep their weights
the same so in one round this is true
that Q I + 1 is less than q i plus
Epsilon
Qi why because these were the only part
that you double the weight there are
very few things that are not covered so
you only double these weights okay so
you get this one so Q is not increasing
by
much s yes just
notationally Q to the power R is q for
round r or it's Q to the expon it to the
sorry you're right that should I should
do it maybe like this round R yes but
this is an actual
exponentiation this one
yes same
to so now how do I want to do this
analysis I want to do a primal dual
analysis I want to say that
look one of these things is going to
happen in each round you are picking a
Vertex cover
no what are sizes of these vertex covers
suppose I did not succeed in solving the
problem these vertex covers are going to
be a small no
[Applause]
so let's m is matching
size the maximum matching size ing okay
suppose my algorithm is not doing
something good so it means that m is
always less than 1 minus Epsilon mu
G if M ever becomes large I'm done no
one of the matchings I found is a large
matching and at the end you just return
the largest matching you found that's
what you do in the algorithm okay so
then M has always been a small if m is
always a small what do I
know now the only thing I have to use is
quic
theorem m is always equal to U bipar
graph maximum matching and minimum
vertex cover are the same okay so it
means that U is always a
small or in other words these UI that
I'm finding across all the rounds they
are very as
small good so it means that their
average is as small okay okay so Define
us
star be 1 / R summation I = 1 to R UI
this is a fractional solution okay you
put Mass over vertices this thing is a
small in
total but I want to say that us star
cannot be a Vertex cover of the graph in
fact usar is going to be very far from a
good vertex cover
Why Us star have
less than 1us Epsilon
M I agree it's a fractional
vertex if us star can cover all the
edges
completely okay then us star will become
a Vertex cover of my graph a Vertex
cover that has size much smaller than
the matching of the graph the matching
has Sid
mu okay so us star itself cannot cover
all all the
edges in fact maybe the so
plan exist an e such
that
plus let's say this way there exist an
HED e such that e was not
covered more than Epsilon time r
there is an edge in the graph that I did
not cover it many many times okay why
not suppose every Edge I covered them
more than this
like yes suppose every Edge was covered
more than one minus Epsilon R
times when I take the average it means
that us star covers every Edge at the
ratio of one minus Epsilon so even if I
boost its number and multiply us Star
by divided by 1 minus Epsilon that's a
valid fractional vertex cover of my
graph and what is its size its size is
less than
[Applause]
mu so there is an edge that I'm not
covering you know this us star that I'm
getting cannot be a one minus Epsilon
approximate
vertex okay if it is
then my like my graph has a Vertex cover
which is a smaller than its matching and
that cannot happen does that make
sense if I have that what does it mean
it means that there is an edge that has
not been covered Epsilon R
times okay so its weight should have
gone very high no this is going to tell
me that that one Edge on its own
contributes 2 to the Epsilon R to the
weight every time I didn't call cover it
I double its weight so its weight went
very
high this is the number of time it was
covered okay so then you were not
covered Epsilon R times and each time
that you are not covered you your weight
gets doubled oh okay I got it so there
is an edge that was not okay I got it
yeah yes was not cover
yes
if you put these two things together it
is going to force R to put these two
together it is going to force R to be
less than logam over for log
overs this is just an inequality you can
you can bound this thing
by two to the I don't know 3 Epsilon R
over 4 plus
log 1 + x is less than to the
1.5x that's just that so if you do that
you can bound that you cannot run this
for many time and this this part of the
analysis is very similar to
multiplicative it is
multiplicative and you'll get this one
so after these many rounds you're done
basically okay one of your matchings
should have been large enough you can
just return
that all right well I'm done good so let
me just take one minute to wrap up then
so so this was the algorithm for the
bipartite case for the nonbipartite
weighted matching the only thing you
have to do is to change vertex cover to
the Dual of nonbipartite matching that's
the oddset
cover you are covering the edges by odd
set size I don't know what is the
combinatorial name of this is just dual
of matching poish
okay you pick that the rest is the same
and when you are doing the sampling now
that you have weights you sample
proportional to the weight of the edge
as
well and the only thing in the bipartite
case that non-bipartite case that become
a bit different is this
argument because vertex cover there are
only two to the end vertex cover but ODS
set covers there are two to the two to
the N of them so you cannot just go
ahead and directly Union bound over them
but then you apply coning how much
theorem from linear programming that you
don't have to worry about all of them
you have to worry about a laminar family
of them their numbers are a small the
same analysis like as it is will go
through
for and that's all I wanted to say thank
you any additional questions for
Seer you said it was in sorry
there one comment you made in terms of
sketching it was this it gave you the
same result as anuar 18 but in terms of
streaming it applications so for
instance in a
streaming uh this can be done
deterministically okay you don't need to
do
sampling I can show you a deterministic
way of finding the edges without without
any
sampling which is very different when
this ag18 you always have to do a samp
cool okay
thanks other
questions let's thank him one more time
and we have a break for a little under
half an hour so 11:45 is the next
talk